well
one last time around for this doctor and
this creator
let's get started
[Music]
series 13 or as we are uh currently
knowing it doctor who
flux
and uh this is the first episode the
halloween apocalypse now let let's be
blunt about a few things going into this
i didn't have um
particularly high expectations i mean
look
i'll be honest
there are things that i've liked during
this run of doctor who there are
characters i've liked episodes i've
liked moments i've loved
but almost none of them had chris
chibnall's direct involvement as the
writer so the fact that he is writing
this entire last series is cause for
some worry
that said
i have also seen broad church and while
the tone and mood of broadchurch is a
completely different beast he did kind
of do better with serialization i feel
in general than he has with episodic at
least in terms of um comparing that to
his doctor who output up to this point
so
maybe
eh look here's the thing that makes this
actually
really difficult to talk about
whether this is a decent
setup episode for what's going to come
or a terrible setup episode for what's
going to come
is going to largely depend on whether
the setups work
whether what the things they're setting
up for pay off and are enjoyable and fun
and go down well
because if they don't
then this retroactively is going to be
just the bad starting point for things
that didn't work
but if it does turn out good
i'm not necessarily claiming it will but
hypothetically if it does turn out well
then what that means is it just had a
slightly
um
awkward and but very utilitarian start
and even here there are bits and parts
and moments that i like but you'll
notice that of the options i gave this
either being terrible or
or serviceable basically
i didn't put great as an option because
for something to be great at least in my
estimation it has to be great in and of
itself as a standalone piece
it's a big part of why when i talk about
ranking episodes i do two-parters as one
story because i have to take it as a
collective piece because looking at any
one half by itself usually it's not as
strong
so yeah this is not good
but it might be decent
depending entirely on where we go from
like let me put it this way this
reminded me more than a little of
thinking back on the first season of
lost now
whatever you think about how lost turned
out that first season was super exciting
with all the things it was setting up
and all the mysteries
it's only when you get to the end and
you realize how much of it they are
never going to address address in a way
that is not particularly satisfying or
just
otherwise drop the ball or string the
whole thing out longer for them than it
can support they realize oh all those
setups were kind of nothing that's kind
of what i mean by you need to know what
this is setting up for now the loss
comparison is a little shaky because
that was five seasons this is six
episodes total we're talking about but
i'm that's what i mean in terms of
whether or not we're going to look back
at this and say well this was yes just a
setup episode but it was setting up good
stuff or if this was just a setup
episode for yeah
we don't know and we won't
until another five episodes go past
the main reason that i would never call
this a great episode
is because
i could barely keep track of everything
being added into the mix
and as of yet
almost none of it is connected
it's all just thrown in and so i'm gonna
see if i can even remember everything
here okay so we've got dan the new
companion he needs to get introduced
we've got the entire thing with i cannot
remember the character's name or the
species name but the dog alien um i'll
come back to him because i actually
liked him a lot so like i do want to
give credit where credit's due but
we have we have the dog alien who
kidnaps him we have the flux as a danger
we have this guy on an observation thing
linder i think was his name um who we
have established while we
ha while we watch the flux completely
wipe out entire populated planets i
don't know exactly why we're supposed to
care about this one guy but again i'll
come back to him uh so we've got all
that going on we we have this being who
has been caged in prison since the
beginning of time he claims and claims
to have been battling the doctor yet the
doctor doesn't know who he is he has
uncovered his sister who
is also bad news i guess and there's
some woman from
the future or the past or somehow
connected to the doctor who
bumps into them but then runs into a
weeping angel we don't know how the
weeping angels factor into this we know
santarans are watching and are doing
their own thing this is a lot and it
lacks any one central thing to latch
onto the closest we get
to a central pillar for this whole thing
is dan
but the only things that connect to him
is the dog alien and then the flux a
little bit because the reason the dog
aliens are there is they are trying to
save humanity from the flux so okay
we've connected to oh and there's also
the stuff back in
liverpool in the 18 whatevers with the
mining thing which i completely
forgotten about except we saw a clip of
the guy at the very end of the episode
so yeah
throw that on the mix
but so far we have tied
those three things together but nothing
else connects right now
and this
might be less aggravating
if it weren't for the fact that we've
actually got a lot of dangling plot
threads from the last few series that
chibnall has written
that still haven't been tied up and look
i'm not a continuity hound
i don't need every little single detail
tied up and perfect and like oh there we
go that's exactly how i want it to be
no i don't need that
you can leave a few dangling threads
here or there
but the timeless child and the fugitive
doctor
are really massive threads
neither of which has really been tied up
properly yes we now know what the
timeless child is but
so what
it has had zero practical impact on
anything so far
and then you know i would say the
fugitive doctor ties into that but you
do
while i'm not a continuity hound there
are a couple of basic fundamental
questions that need to be answered about
the fugitive doctor the main one being
where in the hell in the doctor's life
does she fit
because you can't just sell the idea
that she's pre-heart no because if she
does her tardis shouldn't look like a
phone box
and that's actually kind of the thing
the opening scene on this i think
illustrates a lot of
what's been
aggravating um about some of not all but
some of chibnall's stuff
because i've said before even going back
to series 11 this
looks good i mean like not cinema
quality this is still bbc budget after
all but it's shot well the effects are
pretty decent for the most part it looks
good
but that opening scene
feels like the embodiment of spectacle
over all else because you know you have
this hologram thing and they're dangling
upside down and there's an acid thing
beneath them and there's these little
robots that are prepared to kill them if
they try and break loose and like okay
but
none of this means anything it's just a
perilous situation that means nothing
because we don't know why the doctor is
tracking after this guy who turns out to
be a dog alien we still don't really
know why she was tracking after him in
the first tank place she mentioned
something called the division we don't
know what that is add that onto the pile
of stuff i suppose um so we don't even
really know why why any of this ties in
but it's this extended action-y chase
scene that's
fine
but there's no substance underneath that
spectacle
and i will point out that it actually
was a really irritating moment where
like they they managed to grab on to the
bar so they're not hanging upside down
anymore and the little little flying
robot thing starts shooting at them and
miss
they're like five feet away and
these people are not moving
they are stationary for all intents and
purposes and you missed
hey
again not uniquely a chip no problem you
can circle back to my bitching about the
the guards who are guarding missy under
moffat's tenure as they just stand there
as she
clearly gets out of handcuffs anyways
it's just
it's a lot
and it's a lot to layer in
that first of all it feels like almost
too much to even be dealt with in six
episodes by itself
and it means one of two things
either
it means chimney just dropped
the timeless child and the fugitive
doctor as
threads to be pulled at all
and this is the story he's gonna do now
which if that's the case is infuriating
because
those were big deals you pulled
and while i didn't like the timeless
child
i would like it to have a reason to
exist
i would like to know what stories you
were planning to get out of that move
because otherwise it is utterly
pointless just for the sake of shaking
stuff up and while i don't have a ton of
faith in chibnall as a writer of science
fiction i did have enough faith in him
as a long-time television writer to know
that you don't do something that big
without having it mean something even if
that something isn't something that i
like it should still mean
anything
so
it's possible that's still not the case
but if it isn't that means that's two
more plot points they're gonna be shoved
in on top of everything else that's
going on here
i'm having a hard time buying that this
is gonna get sorted
in another five episodes for everything
that was introduced
i did say there were some things that i
like i genuinely love the dog alien
i love the idea of this alien that is
threatening and has a dangerous weapon
and has been setting deadly traps and
it's adorable
and i think having it be a dog has that
really work because other times there
have been adorable aliens it hasn't
worked for me arguably the slovene are
adorable
yeah
maybe that might be stretching it but
like the peting was kind of adorable
looked like stitch from lilo and stitch
but it didn't work the fact that it was
adorable so i think having it be a dog
actually kind of works with that and it
is it is it is adorable and i liked the
interactions the the notion of the um
species bonded or whatever it is that
for every one human there's one of these
and they're a protector like
it doesn't hold up continuity wise to
anything in the past like so all the
other times that humanity's been in
danger you just didn't turn up there is
actually a feasible explanation of that
because they know the flux is coming and
pretty much every other time that
humanity has almost been completely
wiped out it's been something that
people were not expecting to happen so
maybe they didn't have the time to
um you know do what they're doing this
time so you know
and like that's enough of an explanation
for me to to for me to roll with it
because again it's it's such a it's such
a cute idea
this this extrapolation of man's best
friend to the to the extent of this
highly evolved species that basically
look like they were evolved from dogs
still having that instinct to protect
humanity
i kind of isn't that a silly idea yes
it's a silly idea doctor who is allowed
to be silly that's fine
i did enjoy that
i kind of like dan
he's a nice guy he's uh he's obviously
out of his depth but i like the degree
to which he
does he i like that he doesn't just sit
there and go this can't be happening
he's like okay well clearly this is
happening so
what does that mean and that he's able
to like get under the the dog alien skin
that way like well no i know you won't
kill me because you went through all
this trouble to kidnap me if you wanted
to come and you would have done it back
there so i know you're not ghana
which is a very logical thing and it's
something that only someone who has
barreled past the i can't believe this
is happening phase can think out and so
i like that about him and he's just in
general an affable guy
so i'm i'm liking him just fine so far i
kind of liked the a little bit of um
sort of
regional animosity between him and yaz
that was kind of that was kind of fun
that's kind of cute
i don't know what to think about too
much else of what's going on here
i don't know what to think about
this woman with the weeping angel
i don't know what to think about these
weird somewhat crystalline like
skeletal nose looking things
i don't know what's going on there so i
don't know what that like obviously a
villain but like okay is the flux as an
event itself not enough do we need a
villain personified as well i mean
they'll probably get tied together at
some point but again that
that's the thing
so many things are unconnected it's just
a ton of stuff
that happens in the same space
and that is why i
didn't say that this being great is an
option because it's not even if
everything smooths out after this
this is still a really clunky start
just cramming in everything right from
the get-go before it has any meaning i
mean at bare minimum
have one of these show up later like the
freaking mining thing nothing happens
with that yet save the introduction of
that entire idea to an episode where
something happens with it
just a thought
it
it's
messy it is
undisciplined
it is
worrying
i'll come back to that word
i want this to get better
i want it to be good
i want this error to end on a high note
but i don't know this is not a great
start
it's not a start that's impossible to
recover from oh i said i was going to
come back to linda the guy on the ship
he was nice
like the bit of personality we got from
him you know doing his duty you know
saying all these things you know the
things are still normal all this and you
know thank you for having me out here to
have this view and then to let you know
as i sign up every time you can all go
to hell i'm like okay
all right he's a little bit torn and uh
ambivalent about his situation i kind of
like him
so
here's what here's what i will give that
this does better than actually a fair
amount of stuff that has gone on in
chimneys era it's done a pretty succinct
job of introducing some of the new
characters because a lot of the
one-off or short-lived characters
really
just didn't
land
at all and like i felt like i had no
idea who those people were i'm not sure
i could give you a full character
breakdown of someone like linda or dan
but i feel like i got my head wrapped
around them and how much you want to
chalk that up to the writing and how
much you want to chalk that up to the
actors being able to elevate the writing
i don't know but it doesn't matter i am
interested to see those characters show
up again
and
that's kind of all i've got
it's interesting to see the older
sontaran design again
i would say it'll be interesting to see
why it's the older santara in design
instead of the newer one i actually
don't have a ton of faith that we're
gonna get a reason why
it might just be a thing
that's being done
because
doctor who flux
the halloween apocalypse
it just seems like such unnecessary
steak raising it's just layer on layer
on layer on layer on problem on problem
on problems like just give me one
problem and do a deep dive into that and
make me care
this is too much
we'll see if it evens out next time
fingers crossed whatever your thoughts
are on this drop something down the
comments let's talk about it
there's the usual stuff like share
subscribe i have a patreon you can
support what i do and um i don't know
help me get
newer cosplay stuff we're gonna have a
new doctor in a couple years i'm gonna
have to get a new cosplay help me out
that'd be great but
don't don't sweat it if you're unable to
like share subscribe they help me out as
well but uh
no big pressure on that either
because
at the end of the day
you are the council and i am just
running the meeting so until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and look at you
sticking around through the credits i
appreciate that well you know what
you're about to be treated to a whole
ton of names going by on the screen but
there's a few of them that i want to
give special attention to my special
thanks to bookworm jared boyce mj tracy
scrabbit vincent paul bartolucci kailyn
schwartz edelen hannah acker robin moore
ross schultz and shayla gourley if you
want to hear me mispronounce your name
check out the reward tears on the
patreon but for right now
thanks so much
[Music]
um
[Music]